let me see your twitter
is that a word um [ __ ] hole no
millie would you like some sausage
that's it that's what liam will be
saying
oh millie would you like some sausage
with cheese and eggs
here luke can you put this up
it's just porn
oh let's take a look at this luke can
you put this up
oh
how crazy is this
what's this guys with the show man oh
nothing i just
thought it was a sick clip yeah i
thought it was a sick lip the dude's
dick kind of looks like liam's
dude look at how hard he's pounding her
i bet that's what liam would do to her
oh 18 plus maybe this is porn
what are we watching dude well this just
reminded me of what
it's not nazi for work wifey goals
daddy's sticker chart
oh yeah punch in on these
okay
all right wash dishes 12 pack of your
favorite beer that on the right side is
the reward he gets for doing this each
task six times he puts the toilet seat
down and he's no nagging for a week
i don't believe it i don't believe with
those eyebrows i don't think she can
resist the best part is that the bottom
one is the reward is a bj
and it's clean up throw up and he's done
it six times that was the first one he
banged that one out
my man is an alcoholic dude what how
often is he puking clean up throw up
[ __ ] [ __ ] house every day
wait six more until i get a bj blah i
could do that in the next two hours
scooping his puke with his own hand
into his [ __ ] shirt
10 shots
10 shots
oh man vacuum car seats don't have to go
to what
um annoying kids birthday party i would
be vacuuming the [ __ ] out of the car
that's the one i would have all six fun
this is so sad change change blowout
diaper
naked hula dance from yours truly
babe nice work
babe check it out
pick up the hula dance
[Music]
well speaking of kids i'm glad they're
not doing the stupid stupid-ass baby
challenge for the last week oh don't
jinx it because they might
it's not the last week it's the last two
weeks now
ugh i hope they don't do i hope they
don't do that the baby thing is not it's
not entertaining i i always you know
what it is it's [ __ ] annoying yeah
it's annoying yeah to watch
no just to hear that too humans have
like a natural
like uh
uh what's the word i'm looking for
um annoyance
attraction or no desire
like to a interesting a baby crying
sound
we we are like naturally alert to that
and it annoys us because we want to fix
it i see
so like hearing that on tv in a show you
love for an hour straight yeah it's the
worst it's just it's firing up your
daddy senses exactly yeah it's firing up
my daddy sticker chart
scientists
um yeah so
what they did because we didn't really
explain what they did yeah sorry
basically
they did a movie night
it's like a moving what they call it
yeah they said it was a movie night and
so they all thought they were gonna like
eat popcorn and watch a movie that's
some clever name for it oh i forgot it
was like cinema something mad or cinema
yeah whatever silly cinema
they do a movie night and the movie
night is a bunch of clips and so they're
playing
some sex-based game
no one's spitting in the mouth this time
but it's them trying to you know it's
it's sex trivia how many orgasms occur
in the world yeah you know how many
people are having sex at any given
moment that type of stuff they were like
consulting interview questions for
absolute horned dogs yeah that's what it
was yeah could you imagine if you walked
into like a consulting interview for
like mckenzie or something like that and
they're like all right
how many people are [ __ ] right now
well it depends depends
uh season definitely could be
excuse i don't know how many total but
we could add to that
how many people are [ __ ] right now a
lot
yeah
plenty it's like a ton yeah
uh so
so they do this movie night or they're
answering these questions and every time
one team gets it right
they get to pick from a list here it is
nice work yeah and so
the best one they get to pick from a
list of video titles yeah
and and and the best one is something
like jake the snake or like uh
jake the jake the great jake escape or
something yeah
and
they show a clip of him
egging on all the dudes that's what it
is by the way each video is a clip from
the show from the past like two weeks
yeah
so and it's like always the guys talking
alone
and they're playing in front of everyone
so you get to see like the girls get to
see what the guys actually are thinking
and saying and vice versa yeah so it's
unbelievably embarrassing and
cringe-worthy sorry keep going no it's
fine it's super uncomfortable like one
of the highlights is
liam
having a three-way kiss
and you could
you could see him [ __ ] bricks oh
yeah and then it was so funny like
the best part about all this is
how much toby has evolved and he's
becoming the one who like starts to give
advice when he was the bozo at the
beginning of the [ __ ] scene he said
that in the yeah he was like yeah he was
like
the student becomes the most chat yeah
then he cut himself off he's like no no
no i'm not i'm not yeah i still have no
idea what the [ __ ] i'm doing
with the best was when liam
it shows that clip and then everyone's
like you didn't tell her
he's like no didn't
she didn't [ __ ] ask
and the best was they cut to toby and
toby's like liam
i know it's like dude you didn't tell
her that's when you know you [ __ ] you
don't have the best moral compliment
either brother
all right but you know it's bad yeah i'm
come on yeah
he's like
it's like damn toby disapproves yeah i
really goofed on this one didn't it
you saw you turned to a ghost as soon as
he said you didn't tell her
he's like oh [ __ ]
i don't [ __ ] like i don't [ __ ]
like cuts
um
and then uh uh other highlight so the
the two main highlights was you know
jake being outed is egging on all the
dudes and i you know what i was
wondering when it was gonna happen yeah
i kind of feel like he got away with
some [ __ ] he definitely got he did it
was like he got back everything was cool
with him in liberty everyone else was in
trouble and he just completely slid
under the radar nobody said [ __ ] to him
and i was like this has to the producers
are gonna air this out at some point
yeah i wonder when it's gonna happen
yeah and right as i assume that as soon
as i saw his name on that list i was
like oh it's going to rap and sure
enough they play the clip of him egging
every single other guy on in the villa
telling them to
basically cheat on their girls yeah and
he's like oh if i was you i'd be in here
having fun and all his like explanation
for it oh i just said have fun
i just
come on dude that guy was red as a
tomato
here we go
dude he looks like oh what's our boy on
tick tock who's like yeah the [ __ ]
stressed
face yeah
his eyes are bulging red bro he looks
like a snake right there and now he does
he's looking
i felt it through the screen i felt how
much he wanted to just like disappear
yeah
yeah yeah
that is
horrifying
look even teddy's face is like oh [ __ ]
yeah they're all like oh my god
done you are out of here
[Laughter]
um
so then it shows teddy talking to
clarice saying that he's got a sexual
attraction to her
um and
that
you know set fey off and personally
i feel half of her you know
um
half of her motivation for like getting
all outraged was she was trying to i
feel like
uh like deflect because when it showed
her flirting and talking all nasty
to the other dude sam talking about like
oh sleeping in my bed would you like to
sleep in my bed and all that she's like
laughing and cackling and
hers is way worse
debatable not only that
but the fact that she it showed the clip
of her saying teddy wasn't funny oh that
too yeah it's like that is way worse
it's like if you're gonna cheat and i
find out about that whatever yeah but
like don't talk [ __ ] about my
personality if you're [ __ ] in a
couple with me yeah like that would have
hurt me way more yeah you know what i'm
saying but you know she just like
so she was like trying to laugh and like
you know she's acting childish about it
it was all giggles it's all jokes when
you know i was cringing so hard at that
yeah yeah that's her
you can tell like when she gets
embarrassed that's sort of like this
wall of like emotion to like make it
seem the complete like the complete
opposite thing is happening like she's
in the power position
but it's like no it's you should just
sack up and feel a little bit
embarrassed here this is yeah this is
way worse for you than it is for teddy i
mean she's just got a ton of pride you
could tell like there's no
there's no way
even the the clip for
the current episode like today or
whenever the uh the episode is coming
out she's like oh i want to say sorry
but i don't want teddy to think that i'm
okay with what he did it's like he
didn't do anything
he literally didn't do [ __ ] yeah when he
was like when he was like no i never
said i had a sexual connection with her
i said i'm sexually attracted to her i'm
sexually attracted to a lot of women
yeah i was like i mean that's just
that you got owned yeah it's just
it's a reality show yeah you're mad at a
guy for saying he has a sexual
attraction on a reality show where it's
the it's the cast are supposed to be hot
yeah oh and we'll get into this in a bit
but like
uh shout out to carrington by the way
for
coming out to the you know to our live
show on the ship
uh he told me some things about the show
which you know it didn't it doesn't ruin
anything but it definitely
it's nothing yeah it's nothing you
wouldn't expect
uh or it's everything you would expect
but like to the degree that he describes
it you can only imagine what's going on
here
so
that's the part where i can't for the
life of me imagine why she couldn't
be cool
why would we have to see our void half
naked
affair we don't we don't need this
i don't need to be reminded nice man
yeah exactly we see oh by the way here's
how hot this guy is by the way
hanging out with him feels bad by the
way i know he walked in and i was like
are you sure you're in the right place
yeah
i think the modeling things down the
street or like yeah that the
the orgy scene is down
it's down a couple doors
uh i think you're you're in the wrong
part of the show your jaw's way too
tight for this building
that's way too sick
yeah
i think you're looking for it somewhere
else
i think we put you in the wrong place
man
we're looking for our friend carrington
i think you might have stepped into the
beam
instead of him yeah i don't think it was
you
but
um
yeah so it i just can't
like
it it makes her uh
reaction that much worse to me is what
i'm saying yeah just knowing how um
uh
influenced some of these things are on
the show